quando era pequeno a uma das dos lugares
preferidos que eu tinha na casa dos meus
pais era o quartinho da empregada e não
é por isso que estou pensando é era lá
que ficavam todos os livros
enciclopédias alguém aqui lembra do
almanaque abril
quem é novas 35 mais assim que nem
lembro do almanaque abril
bom o almanaque abril era basicamente as
consultas que precisa fazer prova de
geografia ela tinha lá pib do brasil
informações lá o a desenvolver a paixão
por bandeiras e estudar geografia do
mundo lá pronta pro meu pai porque é que
a alemanha está dividida em duas né
porque a edição ainda não tinha sido
atualizada mas basicamente quando em
1990 então quando tinha 10 anos de idade
a única forma de poder pesquisar
aprender as coisas era ou e na
biblioteca do colégio foi para o quarto
da empregada e ficar demorando a mirador
à la russa e cultural e outras tantas
coisas jurássica
hoje em dia todo mundo tem o quartinho
do da empregada o escritório dos pais a
biblioteca da escola no seu bolso e não
só a sua biblioteca mas a biblioteca de
todas as bibliotecas da cidade do estado
do país do mundo a gente tem o google
que tem como missão organizar toda a
informação do mundo entregá la
universalmente e de uma forma útil
então a gente 25 anos depois dessa época
onde a única forma de encontrar uma
resposta é porque a gente já conhece
copérdia ea a buscar um verbete nós
tínhamos uma resposta
apesar de uma diversão que eu tinha com
os meus amigos era ficar procurando
palavrão na no dicionário então quando
um dia descobriu que meretriz é o que é
e tinha lá 50 sinônimos reboque catarina
quem é de 77 era uma diversão de criança
ficar fazendo essas essas coisas né
ousadas mas basicamente o que a gente
tem hoje é pra cada procura ea gente viu
ali que design tem mais de 5 milhões de
menções é que para cada questão que a
gente tem a o partido empregada que anda
nos nossos bolsos têm dezenas centenas
milhares bilhões
de respostas basicamente porque a gente
vive num mundo em que a tecnologia
possibilitou que a gente saísse de um
cenário de escassez para o cenário de
abundância escassez gera eu tenho uma
pergunta e te que fisicamente me
deslocar para o local onde eu ia ter
acesso a uma resposta abundância a gente
te em vários locais em vários acessos
milhares milhões bilhões de respostas
para as nossas dúvidas
isso é possível graças à tecnologia ou a
inovações feitas a partir de camadas de
tecnologia e essas inovações ou essas
tecnologias que acabam se transformando
em tecnologias exponenciais porque em
vez de crescer ligeiramente elas acabam
crescendo exponencialmente
então se a gente pensar por exemplo
novos negócios e novas empresas na
década de 20 e uma empresa para figurar
entre as 500 maiores do mundo tinha em
média 60 anos de vida
isso já caiu pra 12 anos hoje em dia e
daqui a dez anos vão ser em média cinco
anos pra empresa atingir a empresa já
ser uma das 500 mais valiosas e
basicamente o que a gente tem como os
principais drivers dessa mudança é que a
gente passou até o que era físico e
digitalizado
a gente tem tecnologias que passam de um
momento de decepção pra um momento de
discussão se a gente lembrar dos
primeiros computadores lá e quem viu o
jogo na imitação pode lembrar a
traquitana do do alan turing porque a
gente tem hoje computadores em que a
gente carrega no nosso bolso com 1
milhões bilhões e de mais processamento
e mais possibilidades a gente vê que
muitas vezes elas começam super
decepcionantes pesadas caras e passam
por um momento de discussão onde elas se
tornam populares e elas são
desmaterializados então aquela
informação que a gente estava no meu
livro ela mãe que está digitalizada
passa a existir num computador em algum
lugar do mundo
o que a gente não faz nem idéia e ela
não precisa mais existir nossas músicas
não precisam mais estar num vinil elas
podem estar na nuvem para estar podem
estar no spotify a gente simplesmente
vai acessar elas quando a gente quiser
acabamos monetizados então a informação
do google é gratuita para quem quiser
acessar ou então a desmobilização no
sentido de gratuito mas muitas vezes de
facilitar a gente pega o uberaba por
exemplo uma vez que a gente coloque o
actual indy já andou de rubber algumas
pessoas não tiveram experiência pois é
fora polêmica toda e até hoje tem uma
notícia que o atacante quer cobrar
imposto não é pra quem usa problema
enfim ele é desmoralizado no sentido que
eu coloco o meu cartão de crédito lá eu
vou fazer as corridas eu não tenho mais
preocupar com isso isso é uma forma de
desmobilizar e democratizados momento em
que a tecnologia ela só é discutível
quando todo mundo tem acesso não adianta
ter um computador que custa bilhões de
dólares
essas pessoas vão poder comprar então
não é que esse computador passa a ter um
valor que as pessoas podem adquirir isso
se torna relevante histórias objetivo
isso se torna democratizado
a grande questão é se a gente vive nesse
mundo cheio de tecnologias exponenciais
é um outro exemplo quem veio pra cá de
usando o lazy no seu trajecto é um belo
exemplo de tecnologia exponencial a
empresas antes colocavam milhões de
sensores nas estradas para conseguir um
movimento até que um cara de israel se
deu conta que o sensor já estava no
bolso de cada pessoa e disse por que a
gente não distribui essa informação para
o servidor automatiza isso as pessoas
podem contribuir a gente tem um sistema
exponencial de informação do trânsito
pode usar então é mais uma empresa
também que o javali alguns bilhões e que
não tem mais de cinco anos de idade mas
basicamente a gente vive neste mundo
totalmente conectado com tecnologias
exponenciais
a grande pergunta é porque muitas das
pesquisas que são feitas ainda são
baseadas na quele método lado curtindo a
empregada no método tradicional no
método de pesquisa um pouca abrangência
o resultado disso ea gente teve nas
eleições
passadas um belo exemplo é que a gente
vai chegar nessa coisa maravilhosa de
erros absurdos e piadas sobre os números
totalmente inadequados de pesquisa
quando a gente tem uma situação em que a
gente pegar eleição um negócio que tem
data e hora marcada que tá parecendo ter
se á a a antecipar por mais que as
opiniões mudem existe um planejamento
mas a gente chega num momento que nem
2013 em que de uma hora pra outra ou de
um jeito muito rápido
as pessoas começaram a se mobilizar as
pessoas começaram a mostrar sua
insatisfação
elas foram para as ruas e começaram a
dizer que era muito além dos 20 centavos
mas que raio é exatamente esse além dos
20 centavos
todo mundo queria entender mas ninguém
conseguia ter uma resposta clara para o
que é esse
é muito além dos 20 centavos ea gente na
na agência do trabalho queria poder
participar daquele momento tão especial
do brasil um momento que a gente sentiu
que não é quem sabe agora a coisa começa
a mudar
queria poder contribuir para esse
momento em que não era indo para as ruas
não era enfrentando polícia qualquer
coisa mais polêmica para conseguir
implantar casal que a gente tinha de
conhecimento de monitoramento de marcas
de pesquisa de clusterização desse
conhecimento para ajudar nesse momento
em que o brasil queria entender o que é
esse além dos 20 centavos e foi assim 48
horas que a gente colocou a plataforma
causa o brasil de pé e que apresenta
aqui pra vocês
e diante
saquei luís
espalhe
vi noite está em o homem do gol seu juca
chaves brasileiro 9011 networks em
pequim na china entre 120 e fuma
presidente collor em 1990 a última vaga
brasileira no brasil
max wilson sons ambiente causa prazer e
os 17 anos de história do brasil mano
causa brasil 2010 implementing do sancho
netbooks mídia ótica gols e levou o caos
ao brasil me registrei bairro brasil
andré está no twitter pela rapax em pó
infantil
aí agora sim a mais do que simplesmente
fazer um ranqueamento de hashtags uma
tecla do que a gente que se desenvolveu
foi uma inteligência capaz de pegar o
que estava sendo dito e compreender que
quando a pessoa falava lá que os
salários professores é uma vergonha ele
está falando de educação quando eu
falava que não se pode mais pegar o
ônibus ele está fora de transporte e
criar essa inteligência a inteligência
de clusterização semântica para
conseguir realmente analisar o que
estava sendo dito como é que era a
demanda das pessoas e conseguir
categorizar isso
enfim foram vários aprendizados que a
gente teve durante o o projeto inclusive
a plataforma segue online quem quiser
acessar para saber o que está sendo dito
agora sobre esses temas se pode acessar
causa brasil mas um dos pontos que a
gente que ficou claro para nós aqui
existe um novo fluxo de informação e de
comportamento que ele vem sendo ditado
pela população acompanhado pela mídia e
finalmente pelo governo ea prova disso é
esse a gente pega um pouco escuro aqui
mas logicamente que diz assim a esses
recordes
a gente tinha um primeiro momento onde a
mídia retratava esses a saída para a rua
como protesto e violência
num segundo momento então aqui há
manifestantes deixam um rastro de
vandalismo na rua na região central de
são paulo
em seguida o discurso muda e ele passa a
a a ficar já um pouco mais neutro
atendendo por um lado o positivo de quem
estava sim de quem estava nas
manifestações e se a gente pegar e
analisar o que o governo fez se a
adiantar nosso lá os 5 pactos comparar
com os itens que foram os mais falados
no caso do brasil a gente vê diretamente
uma ligação entre um e outro entre o que
ficou
o que foi mais comentado pelas pessoas
eo que de fato existiu no plano de
governo da presidente ea gente teve a
confirmação disso num outro evento no
pef aonde a gente apresentou o caso do
brasil e uma pessoa
da secom se levantou e disse de fato
para a gente montar a plataforma da
presidente
a gente batalhou muito na ferramenta de
vocês o que pra nós então aquele desejo
nelly cidadão de de conseguir fazer a
diferença nessa importante brasil foi
espetacular ea gente analisou e consegue
apontar várias há vantagens em relação à
meta ao método que a gente criou em
relação às pesquisas tradicionais seja
pela velocidade
jamais uma pesquisa ser tão instantânea
para analisar isso
pela espontaneidade que as pessoas não
se sentem constrangidos
elas estão no seu habitar e vão se
manifestar a partir da manifestação
espontânea das pessoas que a gente
analisa
pela amostragem a gente tem um país
extremamente social considerado pelo
australiano a capital universal do
social media há um tempo atrás a gente a
possibilidade de segmentar por temas a
gente a possibilidade de fazer pesquisa
de um jeito muito mais divertido com
games por exemplo das pessoas inclusive
nem percebem que estão sendo pesquisadas
o que a gente pensou
depois de fazer o causa brasil é porque
a gente não leva adiante é esse conceito
toda essa inteligência antes a gente
desenvolveu para esse momento do país e
se a gente quisesse repente cortar para
o segmento por um tipo de produto ou por
uma marca específica
só que ele não conseguiria ter essa
inteligência assim como a gente analisou
os protestos para marcas e foi e foi a
partir de então o que a gente viu que a
possibilidade de criar uma startup uma
empresa foi que se criou a bloom que é
uma pesquisa de uma empresa de pesquisa
digital ea gente já tem inclusive alguns
cases onde o conceito do causa brasil
ele está exatamente espelhado para
marcas
a gente tem o espelho da beleza do
boticário onde pega exatamente o desejo
das pessoas em relação à beleza não só
estão falando de produtos de beleza mas
sim desejosa eu gostaria de sair com um
batom queria muito aquele a novo creme
ea gente tem um exemplo claro de como a
é diferente entender a conversa e
participar da conversa do que de repente
forçar uma barra uma conversa setembro
do ano passado
a teve uma série da globo chamado sexo e
as negras e todo o elenco foi no dia
seguinte a uma semana de estréia falar
no programa da parte da fátima bernardes
ea gente percebeu que um tema que
normalmente não apareceu no espelho da
beleza que há cabelo afro começou a
bombar li ea gente prontamente começou a
a gerar conteúdos e provocar mais esse
tema nas mídias pela proprietárias do
boticário inclusive relacionando a
produtos e promoções a esse tema que
aconteceu de resultado
durante esse período a gente conseguiu
dobrar o tempo de permanência no e
commerce e no e na plataforma de
conteúdo
a gente teve oito vezes mais três vilson
engajamento 20% maior em 20% mais
cliques e o principal agente conseguiu
dobrar o as visitas no site de e
commerce do boticário então que a gente
percebe que é um grande aprendizado
a gente está migrando marketing que
passa a migrar de um cenário onde
essencialmente se falava se discursava
num cenário onde a gente realmente está
conversando e até onde houve muitas
vezes é mais importante do que falar
entender o que as pessoas querem
entender onde o comportamento delas para
daí tomar uma atitude acaba sendo muito
mais importante
e pra fechar em cima do dundo as aspas
do cara que inventou o conceito de
sociedade em rede
a gente acredita gente é muito
entusiasta nesse nessa nossa nova
realidade de uma sociedade totalmente
conectada de formas de pesquisas que são
muito mais abrangentes divertidas
democratizados e transparentes
então a gente é super empolgado com isso
é realmente o que a gente acredita que
vai ser o futuro ea prova a gente tem
tanto de questões como causa brasil como
o que a gente vem fazendo para outras
marcas
muito obrigado